[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Please welcome Diane
Greene, Senior Vice President,
Google Cloud.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
DIANE GREENE: OK.
Welcome, everybody.
Thanks so much.
So many familiar faces-- on
behalf of our entire Google
Cloud executive team, we
want to welcome you here,
our customers, our partners,
and everybody else.
We're pretty excited to
give you this September 29
snapshot of where we are.
40 weeks-- we're
counting by the week.
So much is happening that when
we brought this whole team
together as one, we're
really functioning as a team.
And I'm sure I've talked to
over 200 customers and partners,
and I've learned a lot
from their customers
and our partners
about the unique value
that Google's bringing,
and I want to really
talk about that to you today.
It's been a wonderful discovery.
And I also want to talk
to you about the fact
that when I came in, we
were Google for Work.
We were GCP.
We were Google Apps.
We were the enterprise
mobile devices and so forth.
And we go around,
talk to the customers,
and I'd be there with our
top technology people,
and we blow our customers away.
And we get to the end
of the conversation,
and I'd say, so,
any other questions?
And they'd go, yeah,
is Google really
serious about the enterprise?
And it was driving us
crazy because we're very
serious about the enterprise.
It's why we were all there.
And so we said,
well, maybe we better
call ourselves
Google Enterprise.
So we started doing
that internally.
We started doing it externally
just to put a point on-- we
are serious about
the enterprise.
And then, a couple
of months ago,
all of a sudden the questions
started dissipating.
People seemed to be getting it.
Yep, they're putting their
money where their mouth is.
They're serious
about the enterprise.
They're executing.
They're delivering these things.
And we're like, enterprise?
That was so June.
We're the full power
of Google in the cloud.
We're Google Cloud,
and that's what
our entire organization is.
It's a uniquely Google broad
set of technology solutions,
products, all built
for the cloud,
from the Android and secure
Chromebook, enterprise mobility
devices, desktop devices, to
all of Google Cloud platform,
from the data centers up
through our data analytics,
the APIs, the machine learning,
the smart data that we make
available to our developers, the
maps APIs for the enterprise,
and our much loved, amazing,
built for the cloud,
completely integrated
collaboration
and productivity suite of tools
known as Google Apps-- changing
the name today.
All of this is Google Cloud.
And I have to say, when we said
this to everybody at Google,
there was just no questions.
Everybody cheered, let
out a sigh of relief.
Everybody feels that
we're Google Cloud.
And this is-- I came to
work on Google Cloud.
I knew it was just
a gigantic thing.
But it's the biggest
IT transformation ever.
What I didn't
appreciate was the pace.
I have never seen
anything like it.
The pace is just relentless, and
it's getting faster every day.
And the totally amazing
thing given this pace
is where we are.
We're at the beginning.
So Deutsche Bank took the top
three public cloud vendors,
AWS, Google, and
Azure, and added up
their estimated
revenues and then said,
well, the IT
industry is something
more than $1
trillion, and it gets
5% of the total available
market is where we are today.
So we're moving fast.
We've got well over 10,000
engineers working on all this.
Since January, 339
product releases,
including things like
new data centers,
new data analytics
functionality, search
functionality for the apps, and
so forth-- these next numbers
are our growth and revenue.
So storage-- I recently
heard that there's
a new health company
startup that's
looking at two petabytes per
patient that they want to keep.
Unbelievable numbers of
satellite images coming down.
You name it, storage,
revenue, 10x.
Compute 4x-- and
we've really enjoyed
this unprecedented historical
bumping compute we've recently
had, where we've scaled up this
phenomena of all these zombies
walking around into fountains
and so forth, Pokemon
Go in a matter you'll hear
later from them about that.
And then, a whopping 25x growth
in managed containers-- this
is how people are building apps.
Developers are
building applications.
It's fast.
It's simple.
You can concentrate on the
user-facing functionality
and let Google take
care of everything else.
Very exciting.
You'll hear more about that too.
And then, finally,
we've always done really
well with consumers,
really well with
small, medium-sized businesses.
And we really wanted to bring--
Google is one of the bigger
enterprises in the
world, and we are
100% on our suite of
productivity and collaboration
tools, Google Apps.
And we said, let's bring this.
Let's really show companies all
over the world, big companies,
how this can transform
their business
and really help them move
faster and more collaboratively
and more transparently.
So we pushed for
big customers, which
we defined as more
than 5,000 seats,
and we're seeing 3x growth.
So it's very exciting to us.
And that includes
over 300,000 seats,
several over
100,000 seats, a lot
of big customers-- very happy.
So the cloud-- how did it start?
Well, initially, it
was a convenient way--
if you were a
startup, you didn't
have to buy equipment,
servers, storage.
If you were a department
that couldn't get resources
from your IT group,
you'd use the cloud.
And people were trying to
figure out if they were really
saving money.
The smaller you were, the
more money you would save.
And then something
happened where we started
getting all these breaches.
A medical record
per patient costs
several hundred dollars
anywhere there's a breach.
We all see all these
breaches, and it
started dawning on
people that you really
need scale to do security,
and so that's in the cloud.
So really, in boardrooms,
people started saying,
shouldn't you be looking
at saving some costs
and the security of the cloud?
I can't tell you
how many contacts
I get from people interested
in hiring a board member that
has cloud expertise.
It's become mission critical to
companies to understand that.
And everybody's
looking at moving.
I sometimes wish the
pace would slow down.
And so that's good.
That's fine.
But the really
interesting thing going on
is the digital
transformation, what's
happening with people
becoming digital businesses.
And I'll give you an example.
If you think about
something like maps,
we all used to go to the AAA
and get our paper map before we
went off in our car on a trip.
And it got digitized.
It went into the cloud.
And what that did
was really provide
a platform for all kinds
of new business models,
all kinds of new services.
For instance, Waze
figured out they
could take real-time
traffic information
and overlay it on the maps.
What a phenomenal
value to customers.
Whole new business,
whole new set
of value-- becoming digital
lets people move fast and let's
them get real-time data and
make real-time decisions.
It's completely
transformational.
And every day, new
technologies are coming out
that let you do it
better and better
and do it more powerfully.
What that all says is if you're
going to move to the cloud, who
your partner is really matters.
You want someone
that really is bold,
that's thinking
long term, that's
built for innovation,
that's going to keep you
on that innovation curve
so that you can compete
and have the latest empowering
technology right away, easily
and simply.
And I love this photo.
When I went to give this
talk, it was my first slide.
I said, I want this slide in my
talk because I like the ocean.
And this is US Faster.
This is a submarine
cable laying ship,
and what it's doing
there in that picture
is we laid a cable from
9,000 kilometers from the US
to Japan, repeaters every
60 kilometers to energize--
re-energize the light.
60 terabit per second.
That's, I think, 10
million or 100 million.
I always keep getting these
orders at 10 million times more
capacity than a cable modem.
Anyhow, the point is,
this is a big investment.
Google has the best
network in the world.
It's estimated we run 30%
of the world's internet.
It's been publicly
estimated that we run
30% of the world's internet.
We reach everywhere
in the world,
difficult to reach places
like Saudi Arabia, Africa.
We have to for our
7 billion plus apps.
And actually, I'll
digress once more.
We recently figured out
because of our customers
that actually Google has 8
billion plus active user apps
because Google Cloud and
its users are clearly
over a billion active users.
But anyhow, so the
point is, you want
someone that innovating,
that's thinking long term,
and moving forward.
This is a very exciting thing.
Google knows this.
I didn't fully
assimilate it until we
were talking to a customer
of ours, a big SAS vendor.
And they kept asking questions.
Well, what happens if
the network goes down?
And well, how does
that identity work
in all the different
places in your system?
And then finally, this
CIO/CTO looked at us
and he said, do you know what?
Google actually has the most
enterprise appropriate approach
of any cloud.
And what that is, is
when we build something,
we think of it as a system
not as a bunch of components
that you, the user, have
to assemble and hope it
all has the same availability.
But if you're doing
data analytics
and the network
goes down, you can't
get at your data analytics.
You can't run it.
And so anything that would keep
you from offering your service
is considered the
system at Google.
That's how we think.
That's how we built
Google from the beginning.
We had to.
And so what that means is,
also Google gets the cloud.
Google was started in the cloud,
Google was built for the cloud.
And so we can even give
you a slider so you
can say, if I don't
want a high SLA,
if I don't want high
availability or performance,
it costs Google less
so your price is less.
If you want the five nines
and the lowest latency,
it costs you more.
But we can slide that.
And because we took the system
approach, we can do that.
I think it's a really big deal.
Google does have
the best security.
We have over 600 people, we
do keep our customers secure.
However, our customers need
to convince their customers
and they need to
convince the regulators
that they are secure.
So what that means is we're
working with our customers
to knock off all the compliance
badges that they need
to work with the regulators
together with our customers
all over the world
and help them prove
to the people they need to prove
it to that they are secure.
Huge effort here, one we
embrace very heartily.
And then machine learning.
Something Google invested in
pretty much from the beginning.
Today at Google we have a
phenomenal community of machine
learning and AI researchers.
We have Google Brain, we
have the alphabet companies,
Deep Mind, Verily, now Calico.
We have Google Cloud ML.
All those research
scientists, a huge assemblage
of the world's best, working
together as a community
to move the state
of the art forward.
And what we're so excited
about with Google Cloud
is we can democratize it.
We can bring it to everybody.
Google Brain open
source tenser flows
so that everybody could do it.
And now we're increasingly
building the tools
to make it easy for
any of our customers
to take their own proprietary
data and train it.
We also bring our smart data,
if you will, our training data,
and let you query
it through APIs.
You can read text.
You can recognize address.
You can do speech recognition
and so forth through the APIs
Direct to Developers.
And of course, all
of Google's products,
as you'll hear from Prabhakar in
our suite of productivity apps,
are infused with
machine intelligence.
And speaking of machine
learning-- so in addition,
we're going to have a nice
cross-section of our customers
today to tell you
how they're using it.
Airbus using image
recognition to detect clouds.
Home Depot, who is also using
our recently acquired company
Apogee-- hasn't quite closed
yet-- to do the API management.
They're using Google Cloud
and the API management
to make it easy for them
to talk to their customers
and partners.
And then Telus International,
the Canadian-- well,
international telco-- 20,000
people all over the world
using Google Apps and Chrome.
And then in a
different category,
we have Snap, formerly Snapchat.
And I think I get more excited
than my 18-year-old daughter
now when they do a new
release because we're
provisioning for it.
And then we'll have
Pokemon Go talking
about their recent debut.
And then finally, Evernote,
which was on-prem,
has been on-prem.
They recently decided
to move to the cloud.
We were pretty excited
to win the bake off.
Their CEO will be
here telling you why.
And we also are pretty
excited about-- we deeply
embrace partnering at
Google and Evernote is one
where partnering deeply around
Google Apps for the benefit
of our mutual customers.
We've also got
pure partners here.
We have Pivotal making it
easier for our developers
to quickly build apps agilely.
We have many, many partners
here in the audience-- PWC
and Accenture.
The CTO of Accenture is here
to announce our partnership
with them and talk
about what he's seeing.
Stepping back,
what's going on here?
Google's been having huge impact
on the world right from the
get go.
But we kind of think
with the late 2013
release of Google
Compute Engine,
we kind of moved
into the exponent.
It's great to be
in the exponent.
It's leverage.
And the reason we
have that leverage
now is it's not just us.
It's why we're
the eighth billion
plus active user sort
of app at Google.
With our customers,
with our partners,
we're having an exponential
impact all over the world.
We think bringing
our technology,
getting our customers
on our technology curve,
it's actually going to spur
economies all over the world.
The small startup in
Africa has the best
of Google's machine learning.
They can do image
recognition, they
can do language
translation, they
can use everything we have.
And so they can concentrate
on their great ideas
and getting it into the
market very quickly.
This is unprecedented,
these kinds of capabilities
for everybody in the world.
And that's what gives us
this exponential impact which
we're all very excited about.
And so today you're
going to hear
from the rest of our Google
Cloud team, our executives,
with announcements
about some new products
that we have in
all kinds of areas,
and then also our
customers, our partners.
And so I'm going to wrap up.
And I just want to
kind of summarize
three big things of what I've
been talking about today.
One is just the excellence
of our engineering
and how important this
systems approach is.
I also want to really emphasize,
when you sign up to the cloud,
it's a bet.
It's a long term bet.
In fact, I have had
two customers now that
want to evaluate Google Cloud.
And one of them
in particular said
that they were kind of
looking for a reason
not to look at Google Cloud, who
wants to learn something new.
And they couldn't
find it, and then they
caucused among themselves.
And they said, you know what?
We've decided.
We've decided, in five years,
Google will have won this.
I can barely say it.
It makes me so happy.
[LAUGHTER]
And it's because of
the technology curve
we're going to get people on.
And when you
compare our products
to our competitors'
products, apples to apples,
they're just plain better.
And we're closing the
gap incredibly fast.
And then, finally,
Google's about substance.
It's a technology company.
We want to partner
with our customers.
We want to make them successful.
We're merging two sets of
technology, our customers
and ours, and that requires
partnering and technical
interaction.
And that's what we're doing.
And Tarik who leads
our customer facing
will tell you more about that.